willkommen in diesem seminar über
determinismus und freiheit sie sehen das
wird zur zeit gegeben dass es herr
hausmann und herr hausmann promoviert
gerade über dieses thema erzähler so ein
bisschen was es genau geht daran mehr
geschichtliches interesse hat und auch
eben zu dem thema bei kant promoviert
hat und wir werden jetzt gemeinsam
dieses seminar leiten herr hausmann wir
schon sagte wird hier so auf die
gegenwärtige theorien in der freiheits
debatte eingehender ist er experte
tendenziell jedenfalls und ich bin
tendenziell eher so der experte
wenn es überhaupt experten der
philosophie gibt für die geschichte der
philosophie also dieses seminar hat zwei
hälften und anders als in vielen anderen
seminaren beginnen wir ersten den
aktuellen themen woher hausmann
der experte ist und gehen dann erst in
der zweiten hälfte dem zweiten nach dem
ersten drittel zur geschichte der
philosophie über das hat einen
bestimmten grund
der grund ist der dass wir eine tagung
und ein workshop haben die an dieses
seminar angebunden sind und zudem zu dem
sie herzlich eingeladen sind
teilzunehmen ist nicht verpflichtend wir
würden uns sehr freuen
wir sagen jetzt gleich im weiteren
verlauf etwas über diese zusätzlichen
veranstaltung für die sich auch gleich
anmelden können wir lassen jetzt
zunächst mal eine anmeldeliste für
dieses seminar in dem sie jetzt sitzen
durchgehend falls es nicht reicht können
sie die rückseite gerne benutzten tragen
sie sich bitte mit nach name und vorname
und e mail adresse weil wir eine
verteilerliste angelegt haben über die
sie wöchentlich informationen zu diesem
seminar bekommen
dazu muss ich ein bisschen was vorab
sagen die die in meinen anderen
seminaren sind denken jetzt schon wieder
diese sache ist kommt mir bald aus den
ohren raus aber diejenigen die noch
nicht in meinen speziellen seminaren
waren könnte das interessieren ich habe
eine eigene app entwickelt die so
genannte viel okas tab und diese app
wird ihn regelmäßig informationen geben
zu diesem seminar und zwar auch sehr
aktuell
die können sie sich runterladen am
besten laden sie sich die jetzt schon
runter weil sie noch nicht haben dieses
kostenlos sie ist während freie sie ist
ohne spionage-software zu viel ich weiß
jedenfalls und sie gibt es für alle
geräte apple und android geräte und sie
haben dann die möglichkeit über dieses
menü dieses kontextmenü hier direkt ein
neues inhaltsverzeichnis eine neue
rubrik dort zu sehen
überdies sie auf diese inhalte dieses
seminar ist direkt zugreifen können wie
zum beispiel jetzt auf diesen aktuellen
seminarplan in semester plan den ich
jetzt mal hier durchgehen lassen der
wahrscheinlich auch nicht wer sie alle
reichen wird ist aber gar nicht schlimm
weil dann gehen sie einfach mal auf die
lokal step und schauen sie sich gleich
online an er wird nämlich auch von uns
regelmäßig aktualisiert also falls wir
jetzt für eine sitzung mehr zeit
brauchen als geplant sehen sie diese
änderung aktuell auf dieser app und auch
viele andere dinge wie zum beispiel die
seminar zusammenfassung die herr
hausmann und ich ihnen von woche zu
woche rum schicken die finden sie auch
auf dieser app dazu gibt es noch ein
anderes angebot
sie haben also damit ein seminar für die
hosentasche die aktuellen
zusammenfassung aktuellen semester plan
ich weise sie darauf hinter sich die
sitzung akustisch aufzeichne sie sehen
das mikrofon als wären sie sich melden
werden sie mit aufgezeichnet ich muss
ihnen einfach sagen hat aber den vorteil
dass wir beide diese sitzungen noch
einmal nachhören können und
dokumentieren können und dass sie selbst
die sitzung auch nach hören können wenn
sie mal nicht da sein können also sage
ich ihnen jetzt einfach mal vorab dass
sie es wissen
audio heute manchmal machen vielleicht
video aber ihr nicht so häufig ist
aufwendiger mit video das zuschneiden
der vorteil von video ist man kann er
noch besser die folien reinlegen das
kann man natürlich auch bei audio machen
und sie sehen uns beide hier aber
ansonsten gibt es keine vorteile
deswegen machen wir der einfachheit
halber am besten nur audioaufzeichnung
sie haben auch noch die möglichkeit
gewisse zu machen marco da erstellst du
dann mal sind ganz kniffligen quiz über
die erste hälfte des monats über diese
moderne debatte und über die
verschiedenen freiheits theoretischen
position
dieses quiz es freiwillig natürlich das
können sie aber auch über diese app dann
machen und sie bekommen eine automatisch
generierte auswertung wo noch
wissenslücken sind über links wir haben
ein eigenes wiki haben sie vielleicht
schon gesehen also bestimmt den namen
werden wir dann auch einspeisen unser
seminar wiki zum beispiel auch harry
frankfurt oder die klassischen theorien
immanuel kant der ist schon drin und
dann können sie von hyper link zur über
lync begriff springen und sich im
idealfall ein dichtes netz von wissen
und von begrifflichkeit aneignen und so
die seminar thematik noch besser
durchdringen
soviel zur app laden sie sich runter hat
sich schon jemand runtergeladen gerade
eben funktioniert sie gut haben sie
schon dieses menü gesehen wird dieses
seminar theorien freiheit und
determinismus müsste in diesem kontext
menü jetzt neun reiter geben wenn sie
mal einfach hieß weiten von links nach
rechts dann kommt da so rein und da
müssten sie neun menüeintrag g10
theorien also determinismus und freiheit
müssen sie schon sehen da sind schon
alle materialien darauf auch materialien
die sie hier
physisch noch gar nicht ausgehändigt
bekommen haben wie nehme ich die
wichtigsten thesen position in der
debatte zum freien willen die herr
hausmann freundlicherweise erstellt hat
und jetzt gleich mal rumgehen lassen
wird sagst du noch ein bisschen was da
zu kurz
würde ich sagen wir mal kurz durch wenig
spricht sprechen sie nicht nur kurz was
es damit auf sich hat als wir gehen
geben sie nur durch also wichtig ist bei
dieser bei dieser liste form zu machen
also in der debatte gibt es einen
riesigen technologischen dschungel das
heißt es gibt alle möglichen vergriffen
positionen schließen
[Musik]
unterscheiden
das große problem ist dass sie sich
leider nicht einheitlich das heißt ich
hab hier wird in diesem kleinen papier
die begriffe so festzulegen wie sie
meiner meinung nach größtenteils
verwendet werden muss man ein bisschen
begriffe mit vorsicht genießen und darf
noch mal ein bisschen aufpassen kann
immer wieder passieren gerade wenn sie
im rahmen dieses seminar sie auch durch
die conrac debatten zu verstauen
das ist kein gewöhnlicher verschiedenen
auf derzeit ist der begriff des
feminismus zum beispiel 17 jahrhundert
vielleicht ganz anders verstanden wird
dass im heutigen banken verschlagen also
das muss man dazu sagen wenn wir dieses
ok jetzt aus teilen vielleicht später
sprechen immer mit vorsicht genießen
mit der games gewinnen wenn sie es drauf
haben schon ganz gute nerven sich zu
orientieren in dieser debatte die
mittlerweile genau wir kommen dann noch
nachher nochmal genauer darauf zu
sprechen dass wollten immer vorab schon
mal geben
sie finden dieses blatt fall sitzt nicht
jeder von ihm exemplar bekommen hat
bereits auf der app und könnte es dort
schon das anschauen also sowie zur app
dann gibt es noch einen youtube-kanal
möchte sie auch darauf hinweisen philo
cast heißt ja auch da finden sie auch
regelmäßige videos von tagungen von
seminar aufzeichnungen
vielleicht machen wir mal gemeinsam der
sendung überhaupt freiheit können uns
mal überlegen also wir haben jetzt auch
eine tagung demnächst da kommen wir
jetzt auch noch gleich darauf zu
sprechen und die videos diese vorträge
dieser tagung werden wir aufnehmen auch
dann möglich aufnehmen und dann stellen
wir die auch auf diese youtube-plattform
und können sich die nochmal nach innen
ansehen
überhaupt nicht ganz cool bleiben das
ist überhaupt kein problem
soviel zum technischen fragen sie sich
als in die liste ein und ist die liste
schon durch oder darf ich gerade vor
allem wo sie ist okay gut genau geht sie
ist ruhig durch ist er so ist schon alle
das aber erstaunlich dann gebe ich
einfach mal ist schon vollgeschrieben so
zu sagen
ja
es geht durch noch durch genau die geht
noch durch ja genau das ist einfach
durchgehen und tragen sich ein sie
bekommt dann regelmäßige rundmails so
jetzt gehen wir mal wirklich in die
thematik selbst hinein und wollen jetzt
ein paar fragestellungen präsentieren
die für dieses seminar wegweisend sind
also zunächst einmal kann man sich
fragen was es überhaupt freiheit was ist
determinismus der titel lautet
determinismus und freiheit
eine weitere frage ist ist determinismus
dasselbe wie notwendigkeit
viele würden das ja prima partie jetzt
erst mal sagen auf erst blick wenig
determiniert bin bin ich nicht frei und
nicht frei zu sein ist dasselbe wie eine
notwendigkeit unterliegen also sobald
irgendeine form von determinismus
vorliegt sobald meine handlung bestimmt
sind bin ich nicht mehr frei wir werden
darüber diskutieren ob es unbedingt zu
der fall sein muss und welche probleme
sich daraus ergeben wenn wir uns
freiheit als abwesenheit von
determinismus vorstellen sind nämlich
auch nicht frei dadurch aber da gehen
wir gleich nachher nochmal genauer
darauf ein
ja dann eine weitere frage ist sind
freiheit und determinismus miteinander
vereinbar dass die so genannte position
des kompatibel ist muss die sie auch
hier auf diesem begriffs platz finden
falls sie es sind wie genau lassen sie
sich miteinander vereinbaren
falls sie es nicht sind nicht kompatibel
sind
sind wir dann notwendigerweise unfrei
oder gibts nicht doch noch die
möglichkeit dass freiheit und
determinismus nicht miteinander
vereinbar sind
die aber dennoch frei sind muss das
gleich in so einem fall ist muss führen
den wir übrigens fällt mir jetzt gerade
ein auch noch mit hätten aufnehmen
können fatalismus
da macht man der aktuelle version die
stimme dann ins netz weil fatalismus hat
in der historischen debatte sehr sehr
häufig verwendung gefunden diese hilfe
fatalismus
ok dann dann ein thema eine
fragestellung für die herr hausmann hier
der experte ist welche tendenzen
position der aktuellen forschung sind
besonders prominent und viel versprechen
sie brauchen das auch nicht alles mit zu
tippen wir stellen die folien dann auch
noch ins internet also wenn sie wollen
können sie es machen aber das schicken
wir ihnen auch noch hier alles rum und
dann in eine frage die mich eher
interessiert tendenziell wie die
klassischen theorien als historischen
position sind auch heutzutage noch für
das freiheits problem zentral
wir wollen jetzt sammeln an der tafel
was sie für ideen hatten zum thema zur
fragestellung was freiheit ist bitte
melden sie sich einfach mit
halten
oft haben
vielen dank sie haben jetzt schon ganz
wichtigen unterscheidungen eingebracht
freiheit vollen frei zu kant kommen wir
auch noch darauf zu sprechen ist ein
riesenthema
aber jetzt mal im ernst diese
unterscheidung weiß jemand von ihnen wie
man das noch anders nennen kann mit
einem anderen begriff als denselben
sachverhalt freiheit von und freiheit zu
genau das ist eine ganz wichtige
unterscheidung die eigentlich bei jeder
historischen oder auch neueren freiheits
debatte auftritt das war erstmal schaut
da habe ich welche positionierung wird
hier eigentlich vorgenommen
jeder freiheitsbegriff hat immer diese
zwei seiten als wir können frei sein
etwas tun das hängt dann häufig mit
kausalität zu samt dass wir dem
spontanität haben dass die causa aus
senden in die welt und zugleich müssen
wir um dies in freiheit tun zu können
eine gewisse unabhängigkeit von uns
umgebenden bedingungen erreichen die uns
nicht unserer entscheidung beeinflussen
das ist dann diese freiheit von haben
sie sonst noch weitere gedanken bitte
[Musik]
das
genau das ist eine ganz wichtige
unterscheidung handlungsfreiheit und
willensfreiheit viele würden denken mich
eingeschlossen dachte ich auch lange
zeit wir sind dann schon frei in einem
maße das nicht mehr zu überbieten ist
oder das völlig hinreichend ist wenn wir
tun können was wir wollen
das ist prima partie total einleuchten
geb ich mal die frage zurück wer von
ihnen würde sagen dass das völlig
ausreicht um moralisch zurechenbar zu
sein für alle handlungen wenn man tun
kann was man will
wer von ihnen denkt dass das die höchste
form der freiheit ist tun zu können was
man will
zu wenige gut ich dachte es jedenfalls
dass es sei und ich muss sagen dass ich
mich darin geirrt habe offensichtlich wo
ist das problem
können sie das sagen dass man jetzt
worin besteht das problem zu denken dass
man im vollsten sinne freies sei wenn
man nur tun kann was man will
wieso muss muss man da noch eine andere
form unterscheiden sich aber gesagt
genau bedenken
bei
kann sein
genau das ist doch so marke würdest du
auch sagen also jemand der in sich zu
einem zwang antrieb verspürt das sei
jetzt mal der wille dieses menschen und
wenn er diesen willen diesen trieb
diesen zwang nachgehen kann
danach geben kann denn wäre er frei zu
nennen
vielleicht auch schon in der nächsten
sitzung dem bringt ebenso berühmte
beispiele drogen eine bestimmte luft
haben und deswegen auch das starke
verlangen starken wunsch drogen zu
konsumieren und nehmen wir mal an der
drogenabhängige mann daneben auf drogen
konsumiert er tut was er will was seinen
verladen dass sein wunsch entspricht
aber die frage ist ob er auch einen
anderen wunsch für ein anderes verladen
haben ganze welt hat und das heißt wir
schon auf einer anderen ebene ihnen dann
doch letztlich für sogar zum
paradebeispiel von einem rad menschen
anzusehen obwohl er steingrauen gegen
tut was er will
aber vielleicht gar nicht anders rolle
genommen klingen sie selbst erscheinung
sehr wichtig wenn man sich natürlich
dann auch die handlungsfreiheit
beschränken zeigte tun zu können was sie
über seine vollen sinne und deswegen auf
das moralisch verantwortlich sein die
eigenen handlungen dann scheinbar zu der
selbstredend position geneigt sein dass
man selbst menschen die so einen
drogenabhängigen kann eben auch im
vollen sinne als handlungsfreiheit tun
können was man will und das problem ist
einfach dass dieses wollen ist hier
problem das wollen könnte ein
zwanghaftes wollen seinen triebhafte
züchtiges wollen
und jetzt können wir das mal davon
abgeben was willensfreiheit meint also
was wäre jetzt noch mal ganz präzise
dann der unterschied der willensfreiheit
zur handlungsfreiheit
was ist da möglich in der
willensfreiheit was in der
handlungsfreiheit nicht thematisch wird
und nicht erfordert wird
bitte
genau am markt könnte man das sagen
wollen können was man will das würde
jetzt ja also auf den ersten blick ein
bisschen paradox klingen aber es würde
schon diesen diesen unterschiedlich gut
hervorheben klassische fall eines
daneben sagt dann wollen können was man
sollte das jetzt ein bisschen anders
gerade auch was in mein leben anders
wollen können okay sein
die moralisch aus dem beispiel ist außer
genannt erwarten das lässt sich nicht
ganz fest als wollen können was man will
jetzt auch ein ganz wichtiges thema bei
lok genau also was wären die zweite
stufe der kommilitone sagt von einer
höheren warte aus sich zu sich selbst
verhalten
also wir können vielleicht mal zwei
sachen hinschreiben wollen können was
man will dann mache ich wollen können
mit index 2 was man will 1 wenn das der
kommilitone so gut findet und dann
könnte man auch sagen anders wollen
können anderes wollen können oder kann
es gerne jemand weiteren schon dran
nehmen
man nennt es
das ist denke ich wichtiger punkt im
würdig ist damit will ich alles in diese
unterzubringen nochmal technologisch
eigens zu fassen ich stand einfach mal
innere werte äußere freiheit
das nehme ich auch ein wichtiger punkt
da gibt es eben dieses beispiel verlag
im gefängnis dieses dieses beispiel
worin fesseln ist genau das beispiel von
gomez an unserer forschung jemand das
leben im gefängnis und ist deswegen
endlich daran gehindert
im rein physikalisch gehen mit bestimmte
dinge zu tun kann ich einfach alles
ausflugs ins kino gehen
trotzdem will sie zumindest denkbar dass
liegen frei nicht ausreichen der kann ja
trotzdem noch in seiner z
alle möglichen dinge tun und erkannt vor
allem alle münchen verschiedenen dinge
wollen wir können eben dann trotzdem
noch den hof machen dass er bestimmte
dinge wie ihr gleich wollen sollte und
er könnte wohl auch seinen willen
bestimmen also er wäre durchaus auch
willens frei im gefängnis das ist ja das
spannende dass man selbst wenn man ihn
fesseln liegt sein willen immer noch
frei bestimmen kann man kann den frei
bestimmten willen eben nicht mehr in
jeder hinsicht in die tat umsetzen wenn
ich gefesselt bin kann ich nicht
herumlaufen das ist klar aber mein wille
diese innere freiheit steht noch zur
verfügung
klassische positionen die diese
unterscheidung ins extreme teilt die
namen meiner straße ausgebreitet ist
dass man sagt in die innere freiheit ist
völlig unmöglich jemanden zu nehmen egal
in welche sie wünschen übrig selbst
unter folter hält damit stimmann
notwendige meistens eine innere frei er
kann sich immer noch mal leben verhalten
das nicht dass ihm neben geschieht oder
widerfährt und eben etwas anders wollen
was natürlich dann auch umstritten ob
man nicht auch den willen brechen
genau das alles genau und es führt uns
dann auch zur harry frankfurt wieder
zurück zu der manipulation dieses
volumens könnte nicht ein verrückter
professor meinen willen beeinflussen
eben auch von harry frankfurt stammen
die mittlerweile auch sehr aktuell
geworden sind weil wir natürlich mit dem
fortschreitenden technik immer mehr auf
das sind die positionen der mensch also
das was die menschen wollen zu
beeinflussen zum beispiel durch
bestimmte implantate her und die frage
ist also system ist denkbar dass ein
mensch alle bedingungen erfüllt die wir
hier aufstellen
wir können immer einen chip einpflanzen
der dazu führt dass er bei der nächsten
wahl die spd in der arena und dieses
fonds werde auf der spd und er wird auch
die spd wählen wollen sich alle
bewegungen ersten aber trotzdem scheine
gehen ist in gesagt das ist da mich
freuen wenn er das letztlich nur auf
profis tipps machen und also da scheint
irgendwie auch überlingens landes halte
software geschrieben habe das noch nicht
ausreicht und einer der sie müssen diese
art von beispielen ein gefühlter
gesprochen machen den aufsatz sehe auch
lesen lesen werden genauer anschauen
auch ganz hinten ist eine meldung
aus allen
sobald
es ist es beim broker nämlich um den von
holz oder stein als handlungs reine
umgeleitet und der punktgenau aus
dachreiter lebensweise nicht mehr
vorhanden so versteht er sich gegen
rechtes genommen
entscheidende punkte das extreme der
meisten dass es mit dem chip im gehirn
müssen vielleicht regt aber sehen wir
alles diskutieren ob vielleicht auch
weniger aus man legen die auch mal
entscheidend zu sein scheint ja woher
unsere rollen kaufen dem ursprünglichen
vorhaben
urheberschaft sommer das auch noch
aufschreiben urheberschaft oder
autorität dass es besser urheberschaft
vielleicht also der eigene autor des
wohnens zu sein was irgendwie auch ein
bisschen paradox ist wie kann man die
ursache seiner selbst sein
wie kann man sich selbst erschaffen aus
dem nichts fragezeichen
dass die vorletzte position der
impossible is muss das ist von galen
straße
diese these dass sowas wie urheberschaft
nicht denkbar ist nicht widerspruchsfrei
alles irgendwie selbst endlich oder
intuitiv verliebter siebel dass wir frei
sind dass wir zwischen halten wählen
können dass wir immer so voll sind und
so weiter und so fort
und was ich dann gestand findest du
wirklich viele professoren als man denkt
heutzutage die rasten schieben leugnen
dass die frei sind die ganze team
leugnen dass man jemanden verantwortlich
machen kann was er getan hat
deswegen sind wir so spannend sich mit
diesem thema auseinanderzusetzen weiß er
heute ich um etwas geht
er scheint noch in verantwortlichkeit
und verantwortung beide begriffe hin
ein weg ist
eine
also was die spontanität
auch wenn unser wille nicht ganz klar
das ging zu einem land der welt so ein
bisschen in die richtung wie sie diese
auch angeschaut sich eigentlich sind
moderne hirnforschung an und weist
darauf hin dass es da an bestimmte
momente gibt bei einer entscheidung
unserer entscheidung zwischen dinge wo
die unentschlossen
der ex libris tisch im gleichgewicht
sind auch ex libris muss
[Musik]
wir kommen noch auf den zu sprechen der
isn kandidatin wir behandelt werden
wobei diese dieses gleichgewicht hast du
jetzt gerade angesprochen hast dieses
fleckvieh librium das ist ja dann auch
so ein bisschen was erstmal von
negativer freiheit also durch dieses
gleichgewicht kommen wir in ein
indifferenz zustand wir frei sind von
bestimmungen sei nicht der reinen
bestimmung losigkeit aus der wir uns
selbst bestimmen können
hoch umstritten
es ist eben dass der esel zwischen zwei
aufgestellten genau gleich weit entfernt
sind und genau gleich groß und gleich
besser ausschauen
sie können sich das dorf weiter lenken
wollen und dann sagt originalen
letztlich gibt es für ihn kein grund in
einigen anderen bevorzugen wenn die vorm
sterben
also das ist so dieses dieses berühmte
bittet test irgendwie versucht plausibel
zu machen dass aus einer völligen
unbestimmt einer völligen in die fans
heraus lässt niemals wirklich
entscheiden könnten zwischen alternative
philosophie immer wieder neuen gewändern
diskutieren und da werden wir darauf
dass nur sein schreibt hier noch im
prinzip der alternativen möglichkeiten
und könnte das ab
so war das immer abgekürzt das scheint
etwas wichtiges das sein was sich auf
die willensfreiheit bezieht anders
wollen können prinzip der alternativen
möglichkeit das wird auch ein
riesenthema in diesem seminar sein
ja ich denke gibt es auch meldungen ja
bitte
[Musik]
ja ja und wir haben ja auch verschiedene
startbedingungen wir haben verschiedene
körper die die evolution hervorgebracht
hat und wenn wir den selben naturgesetz
unterliegen wird sich aufgrund der
unterschiedlichen startbedingungen
unsere körper auch anderes ergeben
unserem wollen und handeln also wir sind
ja nicht alle gleich geartete natürlich
also dass ich denke durch die
unterschiedlichen ausgangsbedingungen
könnte man selbst in so einem total
deterministischen notwendigkeit system
nur logisch da komme auch noch drauf
also praktisch reduzierbar das ist so
der erste punkt natur gesetzlicher pre
determinismus für unterschiedliches
objekte unterschiedliche handlungen
reduzieren wir müssen nicht alle
dasselbe tun
wir täten alles auf unterschiedliche
weise aus unhintergehbare notwendigen
gründen die wir nicht mehr zur verfügung
hätten in unserem freien wollen es ist
dieser naturgesetzlich pre determinismus
haben sonst den punkt wir haben jetzt
natürlich noch lange nicht alle begriffe
hier versammelt aber ich denke so vom
überblick her ich fotografiert es
nachher auch also sie finden das dann
auch auf dieser seite philo cast ist es
recht repräsentativ da ist eine meldung
also werden sie damit einverstanden wenn
ich autonomie zu urheberschaft
hinschreiben und auch in diesem bereich
von verantwortlichkeit verantwortung
können sie mal erklären was autonomie
bedeutet
[Musik]
ja genau
selbstbestimmung genau vom griechischen
autors selbst und neues gesetz also
selbst gesetzgebung und wie sie alle
wissen das wird vor allem bei immanuel
kant eine rolle spielen indem wir zwei
sitzungen widmen werden bekommt gleich
noch mehr darauf zu sprechen
er sagt im autonomie und es ist also
selbst gesetzgebung aber ich denke fast
noch besser beschrieben als
selbstbestimmung weil dieses gesetz
geben ja noch nicht heißt dass wir
danach handeln wenn ich mir selbst ein
gesetz geben
dann gebe ich mir halt und dann bin ich
vielleicht hier auf der willensfreiheit
ebene aber dass wir vielleicht noch
wichtiger punkt um wirklich frei zu sein
beton auch wirklich muss ich eben
willens freie plus handlungsfreiheit
sein also klose will freiheit ist völlig
unbefriedigend oder wenn ich mein wille
da schön bestimmen und am ende nicht zum
handlung übergehen kann deswegen finde
ich dieses bestimmende momenten
selbstbestimmung noch ein bisschen
stärker weil das auch schon so eine art
von triebfeder impliziert seine
motivation das frei gewollte entschieden
auch in eine handlung überführen zu
können
wir müssen immer fragen wie komme von
der willensfreiheit zur
handlungsfreiheit
selbstbestimmung oder auch hat mir davor
schon ein bisschen bei der negative
freie also bereit sei
ich werde bestimmt und es scheint so ein
element zu sein dass wir da vorne ein
konkretes beispiel mit von leben
implantierten chip hat den dazu bringen
zu wollen
das habe es gegeben die welt und so
weiter fasten zu fehlen scheint es
gerade diese selbstbestimmung er es
nicht er oder sein wollen es gebe
bestimmte es eben nicht frei von etwas
das den haushalt und sein einfluss
bereits und es scheint ein grund zu sein
warum ein obwohl er und was er will
obwohl der preis sogar letztlich die
freiheit und die möglichkeit noch
absprechen sollte davon kann was gesehen
zu haben dass da ein wichtiger punkt das
was er in autonomen was wir vielleicht
heute eher die selbstbestimmung
nationale selbstbestimmung zu lassen
das ohne meldung
[Musik]
hannelore bekannt bin ich auch mal
vorbei
ich bin bestimmt
genau der wilke begriff das ist ein
riesending da habe ich mich sehr mit
beschäftigt willkür heißt ja eigentlich
nur die kür des willens küren kommt aus
dem mittelhochdeutschen gießen und des
englischen wortes ist damit verwandt
also wählen auserkoren wenn jemand
auserkoren ist dann ist er erwählt
worden und die willkür bedeutet eben die
kür des willens die wahl des willens und
jetzt kann man sich fragen
die heutige wird verwendung von wilke
ist wie sie sagen also die alltags
verbindung ist es ist willkürlich das
war ein willkürakt das war völlig
grundlos da hat je eine person eine
handlung begangen
aus reiner lust und laune heraus ohne
sich irgendwie gedanken darüber zu
machen oder einfach vielleicht sogar
etwas irrationales getan einfach um der
irrationalität will und da würden wir
heutzutage sagen so eine handlung können
wir nicht guten gewissens frei nennen
ich denke dass und selbst auch bei kant
der willkür begriff möglich sehr
ambivalent ist es gibt eine bedeutung
von willkür die durchaus diesen
erfordernissen genügt die sie jetzt
namhaft gemacht haben wie zb das gründe
eine rolle spielen wenn ich willkür
wörtlich nehme dann ist es ein abwägen
von gründen ich muss einfach etwas
erwählen aus einer überlegung heraus
wenn jemand auserkoren wird diese person
ist auserkoren worden das zu tun
dann wurde sie das nicht aus bloßer
willkür sondern gab es ein gremium die
das bestimmt hat im rahmen einer debatte
vielleicht sogar deswegen würde ich
vorschlagen also begriff der will kein
bisschen zu modifizieren und in zwei
unterschied 2 unter scheidung
einzuführen einmal sagen wilke im
schlechten sinne das wäre die
indifferenz freiheit vielleicht und
einmal lücke im sinne des abwägens von
gründen so delikat even freiheitsbegriff
weil wir einfach diese historische
bandbreite hat und in der letzten zeit
eine bedeutungs verschlechterung
erfahren hat die seit dem 18 jahrhundert
beginnt davor war willkür immer
freiheit letztendlich also ich würd mal
sagen indifferenz freiheit heiraten
differenz freiheit versus der libera
tiefe freiheit der liberation bedeutet
einfach dass abwägen der iren das mit
sich zu rate gehen aber ganz klar
indifferenz wäre zum beispiel so was wie
bei buch wieder das ist in different ich
habe zwei gründe auf dem schirm und die
gründe sind genau so gewichtig beide
beck wiegen genau gleich und dann habe
ich ein wirkliches gleichgewicht und
indifferenz muss ich fragen ja wie komme
ich denn überhaupt nutzen behandlung
wenn beide gleich wie wegen pfade
gründen gleich ins gewicht fallen
also ich dann tun aber das ist ein
wichtiger begriff der willkür ich bin
deswegen ein bisschen ausführlicher
darauf einging weil mich der eben
persönlich sehr interessiert also hat
eine ganz lange geschichte und wir
kommen bei kant drauf der begriff der
willkür spielt als solcher in der
neueren debatte nicht mehr eine große
rolle
robert kah lg drauf ein er geht sogar
auf den lateinischen begriff das niveau
roman petri um das freie wahl und
entscheidungen ein
aber sonst spielt ja eigentlich nur bei
kant noch so eine große rolle
ok falls jetzt ich denke wir belassen es
jetzt erst einmal als sie nicht nur ganz
wichtigen begriff haben vielleicht
sollte man auch spontanität noch hin
schreiben die noch mache ich auch noch
mal zur urheberschaft dieses aus mehr
oder weniger aus eigenem antrieb aus
eigener urheberschaft selbst kausal
wirksam zu werden spontanität
chuas ponte latein aus eigenem antrieb
spontanität also dieses plötzliche aus
fast schon aus dem nichts entsenden von
kausalketten so viel zum thema freiheit
und jetzt müssen wir natürlich um dem
seminar thema gerecht zu werden
komplementär auch die nächste frage
stellen was ist der termin ist muss wir
wollen jetzt aber nicht wieder eine
gruppendiskussion übergehen sollte es
jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr hier
anleiten
haben sie eine idee was determinismus
ist der meniskus
das 1
wenn das alles schon auch in der
vergangenheit festgelegt ist sollten wir
dann nicht besser schreiben auch prägte
termin ist muss noch auf grund er
spricht davon dass also danke dem
engeren stellung nehmen
alle müssen den lärm vor der alle
naturgesetze kennt und er werde nicht
bis ins letzte mittel
und da sagt dann eben der preis also
wenn wir die feminismus war das könnte
dieser verein mit dem wissen was mit dem
vollständigen wasserphobie werden schon
habe mit dem vollständigen müssen
zunehmend zu besetzen könnte er alles
vorher sagen was sie sagen bestimmt auch
als ersatzmann einem geschehnissen um
das ist deswegen so zu sein weil es
abhängig als gibt von einem was
geschieht aber meinem glaskinn
vielleicht nicht nur um relativ genau es
gibt auch ein anderer begriff der noch
ein bisschen stärker ist als die des
determinismus und des des pressetermins
muss haben sie noch eine idee weiteren
begriff der ja
ja genau es muss oder notwendigkeit kann
auch einfach mal sagen notwendigkeit und
häufig wird der termin ist muss mit
notnetz es muss gleich gesetzt oder mit
determination mit notwendigkeit nicht
ganz so scharf wenn in seiner
begrifflichkeit er macht es möglich
er sagt wenn determinismus war es
bedeutet nichts anderes als dass alles
ist notwendigen gelobt
und dann wenn es nicht anders sein kann
wird natürlich das php die frage
gestellt also dass konflikte direkt mit
dem prinzip der alternativen möglich und
zwar die bestimmte person die du
geheiratet hast sagt nur dass
vergangenheit und naturgesetze
die allesfresser und es ist es klar man
muss erst mal dafür argumentieren dass
es ist ein volk wendet ich habe so spies
das ram und als wenn das ein witz sein
also sie daten vielleicht als ich in der
liga
deswegen an sich lange überlegt als
erstes sehen sich viele so genannten
geschaut aber wenn er mir ist es wahr
ist und es gibt nach und philosophen
auch heute den launch a ist wenn er war
es da in manchen fällen wo sie dann
mussten sie diese gemeinde besuchen und
sehr wichtig die ganze überlegung sparen
also das ist dem essen sind die waltons
erste mal hier in der sitzung schafft
rennen um die terrorismus weiß nicht
ausgemacht ist dass der netze sind es
muss auch sgh - folge den köpfen
übrigens als solchen auch noch gerne
diese bedürfnisse auf dem fatalismus und
nepotismus vans spielarten vielleicht
derselben sache sind aber alles ist
bereitet
wir können nicht in der lage sein griff
wir sind nicht ganz es muss denn sie
sind es bereits ein treffen aller sein
können und er fast alles um freiheit es
anders sein können aber auf jeden fall
verhindern also praktisch gesehen sind
sie eigentlich immer denken aber nämlich
ganz selten aber das wäre für alle
sitzen und wir sehen natürlich ist es
sehr eng beieinander alles weil viele
versuchen im glauben des gesamt
auseinander volk wenden ismus war es
dann ist letztlich auf alles
unvermeidlichen könnte anders ist und
dann könnte man meinen können wir uns
keinen anspruchsvollen nicht mehr frei
als die tiere genau twitter
der würde
genau gibt es immer dies gibt es nur
eine art von kausalität
ich gebe ja auch noch in diesem semester
ein seminar über was ist kausalität oder
theorien der kausalität und bin
aristoteles sagt es gibt vier formen der
kausalität kant sagt es gibt zwei formen
der kausalität eine kausalität der natur
ist dieser pre determinismus natur
gesetzlichkeit und eine kausalität aus
freiheit und das ist hier die autonomie
die spontanität der vernunft zu zwei
qualitäten dann kann man sich fragen wie
hängen diese zwei kausalität miteinander
zusammen wie können wir in dieser welt
versagt kann sowohl naturgesetzlich
durch das naturgesetz kausal bestimmt
seien zwar vollständig als auch noch zur
gleichen zeit in dieser selben welt
durch das vernunft gesetzt durch die
vernunft kausalität die kausalität aus
freiheit kann es gibt zwei und die
heutige debatte marke kennt sich besser
aus sagte dass es zwei arten von
kausalität gibt die sandfläche es gibt
auch mentale verursachung das dann immer
so das problem
genau in der heutigen debatte gibt also
scheint man meistens schule ereignis
pausen in der carstensen und die
aktualität ist sehr über und geraten sie
finde es eigentlich erst mal los wenn
ich irgendwie ist das stift auf den
boden schmeißen dass sich die usa damit
wenn das der stiftung wurden scheint in
gefahr dass man das geld fehle
die wahllose stift aus dem brunnen
gefallen ist bin ich es ist ein anderes
ereignis und vielleicht meinen boden auf
dem schiff wären genau oder eine
tatsache die tatsache dass ich den stift
losgelassen habe oder der prozess wobei
der schon eher wieder an der substanz
des akteurs trend ist aber ich glaube so
nicht die frage ist immer bei den bei
der kausalität relation wie sind die
relative schlafen ursachen folgen und es
gibt die möglichkeit dass man sagt die
regatta sind dinge oder substanzen aber
sehr problematisch ist das natürlich
viele sagen es sind typen das sind
ereignisse sind prozesse sind tatsachen
sachverhalten
die geschichte hätte aussehen das war
nur der termin ist oft ein haus an
determinismus versteht also was sie
alles hat eine ursache
also wenn ich mich dafür entschieden hat
zu heiraten und dann hat meine
entscheidung eine ursache und weil sie
vielleicht so eine angst alleine zu
sterben und aber alles das heißt keine
angst hat ein zuschauer verkaufen und
immer so weiter vorstellen das ist dann
eben so eine art kausalkette gibt die
dann müssen wir seine vergangenheit
reist also vielleicht austreten
beide über das hinaus reicht vielleicht
noch ein ansatz gewählt
ich kann die dinge nicht beeinflussen
die geschehen sind bevor ich überhaupt
auf der welt war
und es scheint wirklich ein problem für
freiheit zu sein so windes problem oft
in den älteren der buttons zitierte
heutigen debatten unterscheidet man oft
streng zwischen bereits causa anfangs in
dem wir uns alles eine wirtschaft und
einer radtour gesetzlichen formen zu
kenntnis nehmen dies unter anderem geben
kann
vielleicht einer der erste
aufgeschrieben hat
und du hattest jetzt schon was gesagt
dass es also denkbar ist dass die gründe
für mein handeln in einer zeit liegen
die vor meiner geburt lebt oder ford der
fahrer liegt wo ich selbstbewusst mich
entscheiden konnte und die ganzen
argumente die darauf damit
zusammenhängen werden auf die sogenannte
konsequenz argument gebracht
sagst du vielleicht einen kurzen punkte
noch dazu ganz kurz dann schreibt man
hin ja das ist konsequent wenn man in
der formel 1 kann aber einen er ist die
heutige debatte mit so auch formale
strenge eingemotteten sagen der bild
november kommen zu dieser tagung mit uns
zusammen auch in diesem workshop machen
es möglich große gelegenheit daher einer
der führenden experten auf dem heute im
gebiet ist kaum einer die ära die
zeitgenössische debatte so nachhaltig
ein
also das ist wirklich eine tolle
gelegenheit gleich ins herz nehmen wir
ihn persönlich kennen zu lernen bei
dieser tagung und wer eben dieses
konsequenz argumenten ruhestand
formuliert und so ganz grob die idee ist
einfach ein bisschen angeklungen also
stellen auszuschreiben
[Musik]
moody s und wenn aber diese arbeitnehmer
schon feststeht wie ich mich entscheiden
werden das werden die vergangenheit in
die naturgesetze schon bestimmen wie
meine entscheidung ausfällt und welche
das plausibel ist dann kann der
vergangenheit ändern und auch in den
naturgesetzen sendern kann dann scheint
auch nichts mehr meine entscheidung
treffen zu können
das ist ein großes konsequenz das heißt
beendet erklärt - es war also
vergangenheit und naturgesetze alles
bestimmen dann scheint es irgendwie
überflüssig 30 jetzt noch irgendwie
überlegungen anzustellen was wir tun
sollten richten sollte es im nacken
rücken soll oder nicht
weil er immer kongress videos
entscheidung können das heißt wir können
jetzt eigentlich nichts mehr ein
also das ist dieser grundgedanke
beitragen will nichts zeigen dass wir
dass es sinnlos ist irgendwas gedanken
zu machen oder das ist keine freiheit
sondern reden gezeigt wenn du dich in
dieses raster passt ist immer noch die
münchner landgericht dass wir die
thermischen verfahren programms kurz
genommen also dass nur als ausblick und
ich denke wir belassen es jetzt mal bei
dir oder da bitte young lad gut ja
[Musik]
zu hören
genau zwei richtig das ist eine form der
unfreiheit und auch eine form des
stimmt's 1 die aber nicht eine
selbstbestimmung ist eine
fremdbestimmung hetero nominell zwang
der natur aber der zwang begriff ist
durchaus wichtig weil er auch bei
abhängigen personen eine rolle spielt
ich tue was ich eingeschritten leben und
es hat im direkten widerspruch zu dem
sein dass wir handlungsfreiheit kann man
sich tue das was ich will
okay da sehen wir schon dass es da schon
auf dieser ganz banalen ebene mit
handlungsfreiheit nicht nicht erst mit
willensfreiheit man kann natürlich auch
sich vorstellen dass man dann vielleicht
gezwungen bild etwas das war dieses
beispiel mit diesem implantat vielleicht
auch
wobei wobei mir scheint der begriff
zwang im vergleich zum determinismus als
zum begriff der notwendigkeit immer noch
ein bisschen konkreter ist also zwang
hat etwas fast schon physisches an sich
etwas sehr konkretes an sich nun das
eine sehr konkrete vorstellungen von
determination fast schon so eine
interaktion von substanzen aufeinander
fast schon ein bisschen im
physikalischen paradigma oder
mechanischen fit paradis man richtig
richtig richtig man könnte vielleicht
noch sagen so ein bisschen auch um
psychologische dimension kommt rein im
zwang und kant hat auch eine psychologie
der freiheit also eine moralische moral
psychologie kann spricht von triebfedern
von von am einflüssen auf den willen und
die kann er in seine moral psychologie
mit dem begriff des zwanges auch
benennen
hier komme dann in seine innere
dimension rein glaube ich der zwang
rolle spielen nicht mehr eine
metaphysische man kann unterscheiden
also determinismus im sinne des
metaphysischen
das ist dann zu dieser ebene
pressetermin ismus und konsequenz
argument und wenn man den determinismus
aus dieser inneren sicht beschreibt an
diese innere freiheit dann könnte es als
zwang gedeutet werden in der wirkung auf
mein wollen diese einschränkende wirkung
okay wir haben sehr viele begriffe
genannt wir haben versucht sie etwas in
ein verhältnis zu bringen um die
begrifflichkeit zu klären
wir haben natürlich noch lange nicht
alle begriffe jetzt hinreichend klar
bestimmt aber das war jetzt auch gar
nicht das ziel
wir wollten nur ein überblick
verschaffen und jetzt wollen wir mal
noch ein bisschen ausführlicher eingehen
auf die jeweiligen philosophen die wir
uns hier vornehmen werden und zwar marco
wirst du beginnen weil wir ja jetzt
chronologisch praktischen umgedrehter
reihenfolge beginn der beginn mit den
neuesten den kann und haben zum ersten
mal harry frankfurt wir werden zwei
sitzungen auf
minden marco kannst du bisschen was
zeigen was alles geschrieben hat wofür
wichtig ist so dass es gibt zwei kürzere
aufsetzen berühmt ist so viele motto
landratsamt auf den fersen ist er einer
der partys und man kann sagen dass
dieser letzte aufsatz eigentlich ganz
neue vorher angedeutet hat in der
debatte über die über freiheit weil man
bis dahin eigentlich immer die
vorstellung und hatte das freie
notwendig ist und moralische
verantwortung
also wenn wir uns jetzt anschauen
vielleicht bord gegangen also was und
dann hat man immer gesagt hatte das
kriterium um herauszufinden ob ich dafür
die verantwortung für das was ich getan
habe ist schaurig frei und fallen die
seele von ob ich auch hätte anders
handeln also wenn ich irgendwie vor
gericht plausibel machen kann dass ich
ganz anders
wer sich so handeln musste wie ich gucke
dann war es so hat man bisher auf ein
wichtiger punkt um zu sagen und jeder
riskante anlagen schützen
was hat für diesen kurzen aussetzer sind
acht oder neun seiten was in diesem
kurzen aus was macht sap ein paar
beispiele zu bringen von jemanden der
fünfjährigen glücklich sein würden
jahres definitiv verantwortung für das
was er getan hat
obwohl er ganz könnte alles handeln
können also klingt erst einmal völlig
bizarr sind nicht so muss er auf dem
herzen explosion zu sagen einrichtung
verantwortlich ist wenn man entwickelt
zur rechenschaft ziehen
wirklich weh getan
dann muss auch anders handeln können und
fremde versucht mit ein paar wenigen
fordert berühmten ist heute diskutiert
werden rauf und runter zeigen dass
dieses prinzip sieht die alternative
heißt es falsch und deshalb wirklich in
den bann völlig verändert werden dabei
gekränkt sind ganz wichtig und es war es
wissenschaft schule in einem kunstschuss
von 89 eigentlich die ganzen in private
kundschaft zeuge schönen autos
ok und jetzt kommt zunächst ein pieter
van in welchen wir haben jetzt mal
klassifiziert als inkompatibel ist
ausgegrenzt
die naturgesetze und wenn sie meinen
blick auf dieses positionspapier werfen
sehen sie eine position das ist ihr
siebter position
die heißt mysterien ismus da hat herr
aus man folgendes dazu gesagt wir haben
einen freien willen obwohl die existenz
eines freien willens scheinbar sowohl
mit der wahrheit als auch wieder falsch
haitis determinismus unvereinbar ist
und da mal auch peter von den wegen dazu
gezählt
wer die position arbeitet die frage
gestellt was wäre ein - also was wählen
vergangenheit nicht alles also wenn
lassen
[Musik]
das wäre also wenn verändert ist offen
lassen das ist letztlich größer zu
verlassen also auf der einen seite ist
schon früh spd determinismus war es
videos entscheidung das ding ist
sinnfrei aber meine kenntnisse
andererseits lassen da ist es letztlich
irgendwie kloster zu verkleinern würde
auch das heißt entweder erst war es sich
rein oder es nicht warten bis mich
irgendwie scheint freiheit unmöglich zu
sagen nach es gibt verhindern hinzu es
ist offen
es ist offensichtlich dass wir manchmal
zu beschreiten entscheiden
ein mysterium mystery friemel remains
industries hat alles ist so sein slogan
findet ihr auch auftreten im november
auf der tank werden vorknöpfen und aber
sehr spannende situation die auch viel
hat also verwendbares meinung nach also
auch er macht ein lkw fahrer aus
aufsteigers heraus da schreiben was
hoffen sich das offensichtlich ist
aber ich finde es sehr unbefriedigend
aus die angetreten zu sagen dass
visuelles und stark
aber es ist seine produktion also müsste
er ist unsere berge neuesten debatte
genannt also die position gefahren und
hat jeden tag zwei des eine
heimtiermesse stahl adresse egal stress
berichten kann wieder frei sein oder sms
aus als es im frühjahr den differenz
genau war dann haben wir diese
indifferenz freiheit unter heißen
wichtigen punkt auch genannt zu fall
müssen wir zurück zu fall
einfach mal hin schreiben das mit dem
auch noch mit berücksichtigt zufall ist
ja nicht gleich indifferenz und auch
kontingents wäre auch noch so ein
begriff den man hin schreiben sollte
vielleicht versus notwendigkeiten des
kontingents also okay so vielmals den
weiteren begriffen wir gehen weiter im
programm und jetzt haben wir hier den
robert payne den lippert arie
wenn ich bin die fesche alles über und
preisbedingt ist das ist eine frage aber
gar nicht so falsch ist das alles zufall
ein berliner ist ein fehler gemacht und
deswegen begründet robert kenners uhr
ist eine mathematische norte für den
liberalismus über sein gesicht
die entscheidung der fed entscheidung
darüber zu sein
position die mir zu anstrengend so
erkennt deswegen auch ganz interessant
für uns beim weggehen auch eine gute
brücke schlag zu geschichte also viele
philosophen in der analytischen ziemlich
besonders interessiert eine geschichte
der philosophie und gräsern ausnahme
er kennt auch sehr gute technische
gymnasium freien bin und er schmeckt und
seine schöne brücke dann wenn wir dann
mit den begrifflichkeiten genau die er
dann ihr mein schwerpunkt sein wird und
der begriff für thierry willkür sein
dass lieberum atrium zumindest am anfang
mit augustinus also augustinus ist sagen
jetzt chronologisch erste position die
wir wandeln
augustinus wird von manchen denkern
manchen den karen von hannah arendt
wurde er als der entdecker des willens
oder sogar der erfinder des willens
begriffs betitelt also vor augustinus
gab es noch kein willens begriff im
heutigen sinne es gab acht toten ist
schon so was wie das streben bei platon
ähnliche begriffe der seelen lehre dass
man sagt es gibt den botschaften seelen
teilt timo leds oder andere seelen teile
den vernünftigen das logistikern und so
aber so einen freien willen in diesem
sinne hat eigentlich erst augustinus in
den philosophischen diskurs eingebracht
deswegen haben wir das jetzt mal genannt
die entdeckung des wieners und auch da
kommt diese willkür im sinne dieser
entscheidungsfreiheit lieberum atrium
ganz zentral vor bei augustinus dann
thomas von aquin freiheit und vernunft
ein zentrales thema also thomas von der
queen wird häufig so gelesen dass er
sagt wir sind dann frei wenn wir uns
nach der vernunft richten wenn die
vernunft unser wollen bestimmt also
hatte dann so eine art vernunft
determinismus die frage jedenfalls die
vernunft spielt eine große rolle für
thomas von aquin in der bestimmung
unseres willens zur freiheit
freiheit und vernunft haben wir diesmal
betitelt natürlich spielen hier auch im
august aristoteles wieder eine rolle den
wir jetzt aber nicht eigens behandeln
hätte man machen können jedenfalls auf
unserer tagung wird dann da so ein
bisschen drauf eingegangen noch von der
früheren
genau da wird sie etwas dazu sagen genau
deswegen haben wir jetzt nicht eigens
einbezogen als tröster dann john lobb
handlungsfreiheit ganz zentraler denker
hat aber auch wichtige
gedankenexperimente gemacht zu dieser
frage innere und äußere freiheit zwang
spielt auch eine rolle dieser gedanke
bei john lobb aber es ein vertreter der
handlungsfreiheit er wird sagen
der gedanke dass man wolle könne was man
will
der ist paradox das können wir nicht
logisch widerspruchsfrei denken
deswegen müssen wir handlungsfreiheit
sehen und dass es auch genug sagt schon
lockt und deswegen ist auch kompatibel
mit der mit der bestimmung durch die
naturgesetze und alles weiteren weil wir
nur handlungsfreiheit nicht
willensfreiheit samt dann leibnitz den
habe ich jetzt mal so betitelt mit
freiheit als determinismus 3 also
leibnitz sagt wir sind gerade dann frei
wenn wir die terminiert sind auf eine
bestimmte weise aber beschließt sich
eben nicht aus man könnte durchaus sagen
essen kompatibel ist bleibt nutzen und
viele haben ihn dann so gelesen als dass
er ein
fatal ist wäre weil ja alles bei ihm
determiniert sein muss nach gesetzen ist
die frage wo bleibt hier bei leibnitz
die freiheit die individuelle freiheit
auch alternative möglichkeiten zu haben
oder überhaupt spontan zu sein wenn doch
alles determiniert bei leibnitz und
dadurch auch alles rational wird ganz
tolles rationale system alles
ausreichend war kalkulierbar wo bleibt
dann die freiheiten diesem system des
rationalismus bereitet das ist so unsere
frage die wir stellen wollen
dann ganz prominent immanuel kant wir
haben sie in zwei sitzungen reserviert
die erste sitzung wird der kritik der
reinen vernunft gewidmet sein und da vor
allem der dritten antinori
das ist diese frage wie sich einfach
determinismus und freiheit zueinander
verhalten
ob es da nicht doch eine möglichkeit
gibt eingewählt zugängen in der beides
wahres determinismus und freiheit ohne
dass unsere moralische zurechenbarkeit
und verantwortlichkeit dadurch
aufgehoben wird das denkt kann der
kritik der reinen vernunft erst mal nur
ganz theoretisch und der kritik der
praktischen vernunft das ist ein
weiteres hauptwerk das ist die erste
kritik die sogenannte die zweite kreativ
tier danach geschrieben hat da geht es
dann um moralphilosophie und da
entwickelt kann diese ganze lehre von
der autonomie der vernunft von der
kausalität aus freiheit da wollen wir
schauen wie das ganze dann sich
zusammenfügt kausalität der natur und
kausalität aus freiheit und kann sagt
wir können das zusammen so denken dass
wir tatsächlich beides haben auf reisen
die frage ist dann die kanten kompatibel
ist eine ganz schwierige frage nicht
nach dem heutigen sinn weil er eben
nicht die freiheit in der natur ansetzt
seien außerhalb der natur
dennoch aber diesen intelligenz
sensiblen oder empirischen charakter
bekannt
die sphäre des intelligenten um das
naturgesetzlich bestimmten bezeichnen
auf eine ganz originelle weise
miteinander verbindet so dass es dann am
ende doch möglich ist also das ist die
frage ist ein kompatibel ist eine riesen
debatte welche position nimmt angemessen
zuzuschreiben ist
zwei sitzung dafür und wenn am ende noch
zeit bleibt in der letzten sitzung was
aber auch nicht sein kann wollen wir uns
noch mit schopenhauer beschäftigen und
hier der frage nachgehen ob jetzt
nachdem willensfreiheit oder
handlungsfreiheit eigentlich erreichbar
ist
ich habe mit christopher er hat meinen
kollegen unserem kollegen auch mal ein
ähnliches seminar gegeben und da waren
wir uns nicht ganz einig darüber wie wir
schopenhauer einzuschätzen
haben ich lese oder sehr willensfreiheit
bestreitet dass schopenhauer ziemlich
nahe an john glock ist aber wir wollen
schauen ob sie sich doch noch spuren der
willensfreiheit auch bei ihm decken
lassen übrigens ob nicht sich auch bei
john lobb spuren der willensfreiheit
entdecken lassen
ich glaube es gibt da so ein paar punkte
aber darüber können wir dann hier immer
diskutieren
und wenn sie noch in anderen philosophen
oder philosophen haben die sie unbedingt
mit hinzuziehen wollen schreiben sie uns
eine e-mail und begründen sie ihre wahl
jetzt aus der geschichte oder einen
neueren philosophen philosophin
schreiben sonst de-mail machen sie den
vorschlag und dann entscheiden wir
darüber ob wir die noch aufnehmen oder
sie ja da wollen wir auch ihnen die
möglichkeit geben sich noch von ihrem
interesse mit einzubringen
wie ist das seminar jetzt ausgerichtet
sie haben gesehen wir haben hier erst
neulich philosophen diese drei hier
peter venn in belgien haben workshop und
eine tagung der comma gleich noch darauf
zu sprechen
wir wollen jedenfalls so vorgehen dass
wir historisch systematisch die
jeweiligen denker betrachten das heißt
wir wollen alle behandelten denker auf
diese begrifflichkeiten hier beziehen
die wir uns jetzt mal ganz vorläufig
erarbeitet haben wir wollen fragen wo
ist das prinzip der alternativen
möglichkeiten hier enthalten wie wird
ihr determinismus verstanden ist hier in
konsequenz argument enthalten was für
eine art von kausalität liegt hier zu
gründen also selbst wenn es sich hier um
sehr alte philosophen handelt oder sehr
lang gestorben wie augustinus heißt das
nicht dass der mich auch für die heutige
willens falls debatte uns noch was zu
sagen hat
wir wollen also immer die jeweiligen
historischen philosophen auf ihre
aktualität hin prüfen und im nachhinein
auf die bereits diskutierten neueren
philosophen beziehen also das könnte
jetzt da zum beispiel augustinus gegen
herne frankfurt
wir wollen die miteinander ins gespräch
bringen dass unsere strategie und
deswegen lesen wir auch hier ist die
neueren denker und dann die älteren und
nicht anders herum wie es häufig der
fall ist ein seminar
lange rede kurzer sinn kommen sie auf
unsere internationale tagung sind
herzlich eingeladen nicht verpflichtet
aber doch es wäre sehr erwünscht die ist
am 15 16
november 2008 10 wir haben eine schöne
homepage gemacht wie wir frieren
bindestrich die thermen diesen punkten
nett und da können sie sich glaube ich
bis zum 15 november noch anmelden wir
würden ihn aber doch empfehlen jetzt
schon einzelfrage diese liste die wir
auch durchgehen lassen
tragen sie sich wenn sie interesse haben
einfach einen dann nehmen wir sie in die
verteilerliste mit auf die wird an einem
donnerstag und freitag stattfinden
die tagung und gleich nebenan also
praktisch ein stück hören raum im 210
ist im hauptgebäude total gut zu
erreichen
sie werden dort auf dieser homepage
die ganzen sprecherinnen und sprecher
schon sehen im zentrum steht natürlich
bitter von in wagen der extra angereist
ist und über sollen und können glaube
ich ist und ist in ort spricht kennen
genau also impliziert sollen können
das ist ja auch beim amerikaner eine
große frage ich kann den ich soll sagt
er ganz ein bisschen dieser art als ich
glaube das ist eine schöne gelegenheit
einfach auch mal die inhalte die sie
hier im seminar jetzt gelernt haben
werden und noch lernen werden im kontext
einer sehr hochkarätig besetzten tagung
nochmal zu reflektieren
die person muss sich im rheder arbeit
persönlich zu befahren das ist der
vorteil in einer debatte arbeitet wie
gesagt also viel davon in anderen
und wie wir uns schlagen wir halt bin
ich auch im fußball genauso viel zu der
tagung wo sie herzlich eingeladen sind
würden auch ihnen bevorzugte platz
plätze zu weisen also sie sind dann auf
jeden fall mit dabei wenn sie sich jetzt
eintragen und dann gibt es natürlich
noch eine veranstaltung diesen workshop
mit peter von ihnen wagen und zwar am 15
helfen das ist ein donnerstag direkt vor
beginn der tagung die am donnerstag
nachmittag beginnt haben sie die
möglichkeit von 10 uhr bis 11 30 uhr
raum im 216
sich mit ihm auszutauschen da finden sie
das anmelde die anmelde e mail unter
dieser adresse der tat oder gibts einen
eigenen reiter im menü der heißt
workshop gehen sie einfach auf die seite
und schreiben sie mir eine e-mail ich
bin der der dass die de mail macht und
dann sind sie auch herzlich eingeladen
das ist ein kleinerer kreis darum im 216
wir schreiben dennoch genauer den ablauf
und wir gehen mit ihm auch zusammen noch
mithalten
da müssen wir
im ganzen seminarplatz versprechen weil
es in sehr kleiner aber zu schreiben sie
mal ganz interessant
schreiben sie uns eine e mail mit einer
kurzen begründung mit mehr motivation
warum sie da unbedingt mitmachen wollen
und dann schauen wir einfach so von wie
fortgeschritten die jeweilige person ist
und wie die passung ist und dann kriegen
sie dann rückmelden okay dass nur noch
zur ankündigung witz haben wir noch ein
bisschen zeit bevor wir dann uns für die
aufmerksamkeit gedanken also marco habe
ich noch was vergessen sondern noch
irgendwas erwähnt sommer vielleicht noch
ein bisschen die position durchgehen
dass man da noch mal ein bisschen auf
dieses positionspapier geht da sieht es
alle nochmal vorsicht mit vorsicht
betrachten noch ein bisschen was den
einzelpositionen sagst dass wir
vielleicht nicht schlecht doch am
schluss dass wir dir einfach mal danke
also wir haben viele positionen
also was jetzt nur noch gar nicht
erwähnt
viele sachen zu tun wolltest neuronale
bewiesen dass er ein großes ding
aufnimmt in die zeitungen
neurowissenschaften sind noch relativ
junge wissenschaft und vor und hanser
ganz berühmte experimente sowie leben
unter anderem von menschen liebe es mich
geführt wurden dass die daten spox
gehört haben daneben versuchspersonen
also erst die elektrische gute serie von
vorsitzenden gemessen und hat so scheint
es gestellt das noch bevor sich die
versuchspersonen er bewusst waren dass
sich entschieden haben dass man vom
elektrischen pulsen es war um die 550
millisekunden vor der
gewissensentscheidung
die hirnstamm große debatte darüber wie
man diese experimente genau steuern hat
es gibt ganz berühmte
verhaltenspsychologie meine sehr
geehrten daraus den schluss und auch in
deutschland als blogs oder einem gruß
holzinger ist bedroht verdecken sie
mehrere lose schaffte die dann auch
seitens activision ein großartiger kerl
sagt wir im diesen experimenten gezeigt
die ein euro jobs angezeigt dass der
freiere la diffusion des warum wir
denken vielleicht dass wir uns bewusst
entschieden haben aber schon bevor das
auch bewusst war dass wir uns
entschieden haben als mannschaft
experimenten
verstanden und deswegen wenn von
determinismus gesprochen hätte der
debatte wird manchmal damit auch diese
neuronalen es muss verstanden dass eben
alles entscheidung ein schon vorher
gewusst
wir hätten vielleicht noch die
möglichkeit ganz am ende
[Musik]
total spannend natürlich auf neun
treffer sind und bestimmte
begrifflichkeiten die arbeiten im stehen
die ganz bittere scheidung zwischen
kompletten ist dies eine völlige
standard reibungslos
die bitte aus entwicklung es wird
einfach dann vorausgesetzt
wenn unsere entscheidende kreiert sind
es die landkreise und des relativ hoch
umstritten und deswegen kann man euro
ist eine neue wissenschaftliche debatte
ist auch als philosoph david vincenz
einmal nach meinem ressort und sehr froh
sein diesen leuten sie zu schnell
anzuvertrauen
wir könnten auch ganz am ende dennoch so
ein zitat oder zwei zitate so die kurze
argumentation dieser
neurowissenschaftler hier mal
präsentieren und dann einfach angesichts
der arbeiten begrifflichen hintergrund
versuchen die zu kritisieren da mal
einzuschätzen das wäre eine kurze sache
eine halbe stunde
wir bringen die wichtigsten argumente
dieser neurowissenschaftler und schauen
dann trifft das zu angesichts dieser
ganzen unterscheidungen die wir schon
unser arbeitet
dass erstmals eine komposition aus
sieben tipps zu arbeiten wird zu
internalisieren sollten begrifflichkeit
einfach ein problem wie man das problem
das wird hoffentlich ich habe das gibt
mir leid und umwelt von natur die uns
lieben weismachen wollen dass wir keine
freie entscheidung treffen können
aufgrund experimente wie sie
durchgeführt haben und ich denke als
besuchen haben die aufgabe gerade diesen
namen gerufen du kannst eine antwort
darauf zu haben
sie können sich auf unsere ganz anderen
ergebnis kommen an swisscom das
natürlich immer tragen
aber ich denke es ist sicher so dass die
wirklichkeit - prozesses arbeiten dann
die große hilfe
rechts ist es vielleicht gewesen sitzen
dann noch mal auf diese ganz konkrete
und
wobei ich jetzt ja gehört habe dass
dieses limit experiment empirisch
falsifiziert worden ist also das ist
natürlich hin und her wir würden mal auf
diesem stand einsteigen zu sagen dieses
liebert experimental jetzt mal richtig
schreibst vielleicht auch noch hin genau
eigentlich geht's lang
wer sowas sagen würde ist es ist ein
während einer leider auch versucht ganz
ohne tropischen land haben wir einfach
selber auch empirisch sich auch solche
solche experimente beruft und zu sagen
dass eigenen von krise die man ihm aus
diesem experiment siehst dass die
eigentlich mps also mit der versucht
genau womit einige waffen zu schlagen
ist es wird im gegenzug attraktiver sein
denken jetzt elf empfehlen
wer kann es nicht wirklich aus der wahl
hervor
widersprechen würden
der auf eine einstopp es eben gemacht
professor verhaltensökonomie der
logischen schluss geben wobei das
natürlich auch ein thema von seminar an
sich wäre aber wir würden am ende dann
noch drauf gesprächen kommen hast du
noch eine position marke die wir hier
noch kurz erläutern sollten bzw
da ist eine meldung
und diese antwort erhalten
darunter fallen
[Musik]
bogen
dollar
mustafi
und setzen
schwerpunkt der durch schon wichtig ist
dass also die frage ist die rolle des
bewusstseins feinen stoffen und also
damit zum beispiel die wissen zurück
interessant wenn es zum beispiel um die
sie sagen würden bewusst einzigen
befreit also gesagt spontanität
bewusstsein kontingents das sind die
drei elemente von einer freien
entscheidung bewusst erst mal bedenkt
das bewusstsein schon eine wichtige
rolle spielt wenn ich irgendwie im
schlaf handel oder eine bank ausrauben
us anwälte vor gericht zerrte mich
wirklich beweisen kann
das ist es einfach nur schlafen gemacht
hat scheint dafür zu sprechen dass es
vielleicht nicht ganz so frei ist
unverantwortlich dafür bin aber es ist
natürlich schon dass wir vielleicht
unserem unterbewusstsein schon durch
vorherige bewusste entscheidungen ein
und deswegen ist es ein ganz wichtiger
punkt alles hatte was etwas unbewusst
geschieht heißt nicht unbedingt dass wir
dafür nicht verantwortlich sind
ich glaube an sie ihren richtigen
die natur vor also wir sind recht
beantworten lassen unser
unterbewusstsein so gespräches
geschnitten
also das ist ein interessanter punkt für
die debatte also vom die
neurowissenschaft und selbst in diesen
poren des ganzen teams also in die ferne
sie überhaupt immer bewusst sein
aber ganz spannendes thema
ok ich denke die liste geht noch die
wandert noch durch wie lassen sie noch
durch wandern wir werden jetzt mit blick
auf die zeit am ende
wir bedanken uns für die rege mitarbeit
finden jetzt diese aufnahme der heutigen
sitzung und auch die zusammenfassung und
das abfotografierte tafelbild demnächst
auf dieser seite philo cast und werden
das dann auch per push notification an
ihre handys geschickt bekommen dann bis
zur nächsten sitzung